.
BACK TO YOU.
>> WHITNEY WILD, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TRACKING THIS TRIAL
VERY CLOSELY.
MEANTIME, FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
FILING AN EMERGENCY APPEAL TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
HE'S ASKING THE HIGH COURT TO
INTERVENE IN THIS FIGHT OVER
CLASSIFIED RECORDS SEIZED AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
WE HAVE MORE.
IT'S INTERESTING.
IT'S A PRETTY NARROW REQUEST.
NOT GOING TO ASK YOU TO GET INTO
INDEPENDENT JURISDICTION.
BUT THIS IS REALLY TECHNICAL
STUFF HERE.
WHAT IS THE BIG PICTURE?
>> WELL, POPPY, THIS IS A
TARGETED EFFORT AS YOU SAY.
FOR DONALD TRUMP TO TURN BACK
THE CLOCK.
HE REALLY WANTS TO GO BACK TO
THAT TIME PERIOD WHEN HE WAS
CONTROLLING EVERYTHING, ALL OF
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE SEIZED
AT MAR-A-LAGO THIS SUMMER.
AND THEY WERE GOING TO BE
REVIEWED BY SPECIAL MASTER
POTENTIALLY TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
AS WELL.
WHAT IS AT ISSUE IN THIS
PARTICULAR APPEAL IS THE 100
DOCUMENTS MARKED AS CLASSIFIED.
THAT WERE FOUND IN ALL OF THOSE
BOXES THAT THE FBI TOOK OUT OF
MAR-A-LAGO.
AND WHAT DONALD TRUMP'S TEAM IS
ARGUING IS THAT RIGHT NOW WHILE
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
LOOKING AT THEM, THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS
LOOKING AT THEM TO ASSESS ANY
NATIONAL SECURITY RISK.
HE IS SAYING OH, THIS IS CHAOS.
THERE SHOULD BE RESTORED ORDER
HERE.
WHAT THAT MEANS TO HIS TEAM IS
THAT THE SPECIAL MASTER SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PRESIDE OVER WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THESE 100 DOCUMENTS
MARKED AS CLASSIFIED.
ESSENTIALLY, THEY SHOULD GET TO
LOOK AT THEM BEFORE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT GOES THROUGH THEM AND
SEES HOW MUCH HARM IS BEING DONE
HERE.
HE WANTS THERE TO BE
TRANSPARENCY.
THAT IS ANOTHER KEY PIECE OF THE
ARGUMENT.
NOW THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON
THEIR SIDE, WE HAVEN'T SEEN WHAT
THEIR RESPONSE IS YET, POPPY.
BUT WE REALLY DO KNOW THAT THEY
ARE PROBABLY GOING TO SAY THERE
IS NO WAY THESE DOCUMENTS ARE
TRUMP'S.
THEY'RE MARKED AS CLASSIFIED
RECORDS.
AND IT'S NOT HARMING DONALD
TRUMP AT THIS POINT IN TIME FOR
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, TO BE
LOOKING AT THEM FOR POSSIBLE
NATIONAL SECURITY LEAKS.
WHAT THE HARM REALLY COULD BE
WOULD BE TO THE UNITED STATES
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN, SO IT
IS JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS THAT
HAS PER VIEW OVER THIS
INITIALLY.
THAT'S BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THE
11th CIRCUIT IS ASSIGNED TO HIM.
THAT IS WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
HOWEVER, CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE IF HE WILL BE DECIDING
ALONE OR IF A MAJORITY OF THE
JUSTICE WAS DECIDE.
>> THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
JUSTICE THOMAS IS THE PERSON ON
THE SUPREME COURT WHO IS
DESIGNATED TO OVERSEE ANYTHING
THAT COMES UP THROUGH THE SYSTEM
OUT OF FLORIDA.
SO THE 11th CIRCUIT, HE'S THE
ONE THAT GETS TO REVIEW
EMERGENCY ACTIONS LIKE THIS FROM
TRUMP'S TEAM.
THESE SORTS OF SITUATIONS, WHEN
THEY INVOLVE A FORMER PRESIDENT,
IT OFTEN BECOMES SOMETHING THAT
THE REST OF THE SUPREME COURT
WILL DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO TAKE.
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE A REALLY TOUGH CHOICE.
DOES THE SUPREME COURT WANT TO
GET INVOLVED IN THIS STAGE?
DO THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS
AN APPROPRIATE APPEAL OF JUDGE
CANNON AND WHAT SHE WAS DOING
WITH THE SPECIAL MASTER AT THIS
POINT IN THE PROCESS?
THOSE ARE ALL QUESTIONS THAT THE
SUPREME COURT IS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT.
OF COURSE, WE DO KNOW THERE IS A
RESPONSE FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN ONE WEEK.
POPPY?
>> GREAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE REPORTING.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THIS WITH
CNN LEGAL ANALYST, FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
ELLIOTT, GREAT TO YOU HAVE.
LET'S GET TO THE CENTRAL
QUESTION HERE.
LET'S ASSUME FOR ARGUMENT'S SAKE
THE SUPREME COURT SAYS, OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO CONSIDER THIS.
WE'LL TAKE THIS UP.
EVEN IF TRUMP WERE TO WIN, DOES
THAT FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE WHAT
DOJ CAN DO HERE WITH THESE
DOCUMENTS?
>> AT THIS STAGE, ABSOLUTELY
NOT.
BECAUSE THIS WOULD NOT AFFECT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY
TO USE THE DOCUMENTS IN THEIR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION WHICH AT
THIS STAGE RIGHT NOW THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
NOW, LOOK, POPPY, THERE COULD BE
A DAY WHEN SOMEBODY WINS OR LOSE
HERE'S AND TAKES THE WHOLE THING
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
THE WHOLE CIVIL CASE WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE.
YES, THAT MAY CHANGE THE OUTCOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY.
AS OF TODAY, RIGHT NOW, NO.
NOTHING CHANGES EVEN IF TRUMP
WINS.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU THOUGH
ABOUT A PART OF THE ARGUMENT
TRUMP'S LAWYERS ARE MAKING TO
THE SUPREME COURT THAT I THINK
IS INTERESTING.
SO DOJ SAYS, NO, THESE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS CAN'T GO TO
THE SPECIAL MASTER BECAUSE THAT
COULD HARM NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHAT TRUMP'S LAWYERS ARE SAYING
IS HOW CAN YOU MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ARGUING YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
USE THESE DOCUMENTS TO PRESENT
TO WITNESSES, TO PRESENT TO A
GRAND JURY?
YOU KNOW, HOW DO YOU SQUARE THE
TWO?
DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE -- WHAT
DO YOU THINK?
>> SURE.
THERE IS NOTHING UNCOMMON IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
I WORKED THERE FOR SIX YEARS
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER.
THERE IS NOTHING UNCOMMON IN
THERE BEING BOTH NATIONAL
SECURITY AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INTERESTS IN THE SAME PIECE OF
EVIDENCE.
AND THE MERE FACT THAT SOMETHING
MIGHT AFFECT NATIONAL SECURITY
DOESN'T MEAN THE PROSECUTORS OR
GRAND JURIES CAN'T SEE IT.
THERE ARE RULES AND REGULATIONS
AND LAWS OF GOVERNING THE
SECURITY OF THAT INFORMATION
EVEN WHEN USING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT CUTE TO SAY
THAT MERELY BECAUSE A GRAND JURY
MIGHT SEE IT THAT, SOMEHOW IT'S
NOW A RISK TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
THAT IS NOT ACCURATE.
>> IF THE SUPREME COURT AGREES
TO TAKE UP THIS EMERGENCY
REQUEST, THEY NEED -- YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE -- THEY HAVE CERTAIN
CRITERIA THEY HAVE TO CHECK OFF
TO GRANT A STAY.
ONE OF THOSE CRITERIA IS THAT
THEY AGREE THAT THIS COULD CAUSE
IRREPAIRABLE HARM TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IF THEY DENY A STAY.
HOW HIGH A BAR IS THAT?
>> IT'S A PRETTY HIGH BAR.
NUMBER ONE, A LIKELIHOOD OF
SUCCESS ON THE MERITS THAT THEY
THINK HE WOULD WIN ANYWAY.
AND, TWO, IRREPAIRABLE HARM.
NO WHAT COULD BE THE
IRREPAIRABLE HARM TO AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
PERSONAL PROPERTY INTEREST IN
THESE DOCUMENTS?
THESE ARE NO MATTER WHAT YOU
THINK OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT OR
ANYTHING ELSE, THESE ARE MARKED
NATIONAL SECURITY DOCUMENTS.
THEY ARE NOT HIS PERSONAL
PROPERTY.
SO YOU CAN'T REALLY MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT BY TAKING THEM
AWAY HE'S HARMED IN SOME WAY
THAT IT WOULD BE, FOR INSTANCE,
IF IT WERE A PASSPORT OR, I
DON'T KNOW, BIRTH CERTIFICATE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> JUST FINALLY, WE LOOK BIG
PICTURE.
THIS IS NOT FIRST TIME THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WANTED TO GO TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
HE'S GONE TO THE SUPREME COURT.
AND HE'S BEEN FRUSTRATED TO SAY
THE LEAST AT HIS LACK OF SUCCESS
WITH ARGUMENTS BEFORE THE COURT.
EXPLAIN HOW THIS ARGUMENT IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HE'S TAKEN
THERE BEFORE.
>> YEAH, LOOK.
YOU KNOW, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
MOST -- WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
SUPREME COURT BEING A
CONSERVATIVE COURT, IT'S ON
SOCIAL ISSUES.
ABORTION, AFFIRMATIVE ACTION,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
ON THE MATTERS OF TENSION
BETWEEN THE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT OR SHOULD A PRESIDENT
BEND THE KNEE IN INFECT OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, HE
REALLY HASN'T DONE QUITE WELL.
NUMBER ONE WHEN THERE WAS A
QUESTION OF CONGRESS HAVING
ACCESS TO HIS TAX RECORDS HE
LOST AND SO ON.
SO THIS IS SORT OF A STRANGE BED
FELLOWS CASE.
IT'S NO THE STRAIGHT FORWARD
THING